here in this video we shall showcase to
you the 15
fastest monster stylings and since
many of the other titans were only
mentioned in the movie
or shown in the comics the speed of
these particular tyrants cannot be
assessed at all
we will only showcase the ones seen in
the movies
and many of them are estimated by us
mind cue
of course they are the ones with the
officially release data on speed
others on the other hand can only be
done so with educated measurements
so subscribe to be a part of the mind
cue family and now
let's get down with this sickness number
15 methuselah
the big tatanus methuselah is a
quarterback monster with a forest
sprouting on his rocky and mountainous
back
and he has a mouth full of huge razor
sharp fangs he also has huge horns
his full limbs have claws while his hind
limbs have hooves
which makes him walk in a peculiar
fashion methuselah has a lagging reptile
tail as well
all this point out to one thing
methuselah with his crouching posture
is the slowest of the titans and his
speed would be less than 100 miles per
hour
at best or around 160 kilometers per
hour
number 14 the skull crawlers from 2017.
the 2017 kong skull island skull
crawlers
are large reptilian creatures with only
two long four limbs and no hind limbs
as well as a long prehensile serpentine
tail they have
long and slender yet muscular sturdy
bodies but because they drag their long
tails and have only two hands
these characteristics slow them down but
the big one still could reach top speeds
of more than 100 miles per hour
or 160 kilometers per hour as seen in
the fight with gong
in the final parts of the movie number
13
behemoth the next one is titanos
behemoth and it resembles a prehistoric
ground sloth with huge curving tusks
that resemble dose of a mammoth and it
knuckle walks like a gorilla
it has brown fur with short taper like
trunks and two long tusks
and his head resembles that of a mammoth
although he walks like a gorilla
his sloth characteristics and mammoth
spots would make him slow
and not as fast as one would think but
he will still clock between 100 and 150
miles per hour
or between 160 to 220 kilometers per
hour
number 12 the muto female the female
muto and the queen muta of king of the
monsters share the same ranking
the female muto is substantially larger
than a male reaching approximately twice
as tall as him
around 300 feet tall she has two primary
pairs of full limbs and a smaller set on
her midsection
as well as hind limbs she walks like an
arachnid and does seem to be slow and
sluggish
but her burst of speed during the fight
with godzilla puts her
between 100 to 150 miles per hour or
between 160 to 220 kilometers per hour
number 11 cilla titanicillar is a
massive armored cephalopod with
six bony lightly hairy legs each with
two joints and a claw
at the end cylinder moves in rapid
bursts of small
quick steps similar to a spider it also
has more control over its individual
legs than spiders
who rely on hydrostatic pressure to
stretch their legs because they lack
blood and bones
unlike zilla siller could potentially
reach speeds of more than 150 miles per
hour
or more than 220 kilometers per hour
number 10 2017 gong the kong of skull
island
from 2017 has the posture of a human and
moves more or less like a human
especially when he's running a normal
human would run around 15 miles per hour
or 22 kilometers per hour
unless it's usain bolt and then just
double that number
but nevertheless kong was stated to be
running at speeds of over 150 miles per
hour
or 220 kilometers per hour and it was
pretty evident during his run to smash
the helicopters in a 2017 movie
and this speed is according to the 2017
design of him being a hundred and four
feet tall
number nine the red skull crawler a
large adult skull crawler code name
number 10 was
held captive by apex cybernetics to be
used as a test subject for mechagodzilla
to kill
the creature breaks free from its
containment cell
and begins chasing after madison russell
although it was seen only in a brief
moment
in its sprint to catch madison it seemed
to be lightning fast like a superbike
rushing towards you
but mind you it was gigantic in size so
its speed could have been around 200
miles per hour or 220 kilometers per
hour
number eight godzilla while retaining
the same basic design as this 2014
appearance godzilla received a slight
revamp for king of the monsters and
godzilla vs kong
with his dorsal plates being bigger and
changing in shape and his chest and
abdomen
shape being well i don't know maybe he
hit the gym
which makes him faster than the 2014
version which just
walked slowly and lazily in its scene of
godzilla rushing towards ghidorah and in
godzilla vs kong towards mechagodzilla
he reached speeds of over 250 miles per
hour
or 400 kilometers per hour number seven
mechagodzilla the mecca was bigger than
godzilla and had the same overall design
its four limbs were considerably bulkier
and slightly longer than the real
big g's ones with zygodactyl claws
whatever they are
its feet seem to bear a slight
resemblance to ghidorahs while still
having the legs of godzilla's frame
it was equally as fast godzilla while
running towards each other in godzilla
vs kong
but with those rocket thrusters it would
have been faster
maybe i don't know a notch faster like
300 miles per hour
or an 80 kilometers per hour mode and
the 400 of godzilla
number six gom 2021 in godzilla versus
scorm the big ape had grown to be over
350 feet tall or three times his own
size during the 2017 movie
and as you can see while he was
traveling in the hollow earth the heavs
which were basically
anti-gravity anti-gravity-powered
helicopters was struggling to keep
up with the big ape he was traveling on
all four of his limbs like a gorilla
and since a gorilla can reach speeds of
up to 25 miles per hour
calm with his size and according to the
shape of gorilla and his traveling
style would have been traveling at
speeds of over 300 to 400 miles per hour
and if converted it will be 480 to 640
kilometers per hour
number five the warbat a robots are
large reptilian serpentine creatures
being grayish in coloration
and equipped with two red membranous
wings running down the top half of its
body
their torso is similar to that of a
snake coupled with the membranous wings
the wabash resemble a cobra
warbats are agile flies and display
excellent maneuverability
and the hollow earth they can easily
catch up to an atav
and catch one in mid air so their speed
would have been over 500 miles per hour
to do so
or more than 800 kilometers per hour
number four the muto male the male muto
has a similar appearance to the female
except that he
is much smaller and has a more agile
physique and his front limbs
have been organically repurposed to form
as wings which are long
pointed and membranous like that of a
pterosaur it had been seen to swiftly
take into the air and fly around san
francisco while fighting godzilla
with speeds that is faster than the
warbat but slower than mothra
at maybe between 500 to 600 miles per
hour and converted to 800 to 960
kilometers per hour
number three mothra while her larval
form is much
more insectoid in appearance possessing
a vaguely armadillo-like segmented
back double-jointed and somewhat
caterpillar-like legs
and slowed movement her imago or major
form
seemed to be more agile or slender than
the previous incarnations
mothra was a fast flyer reaching more
than mach 1 or more than
the speed of sound which would put it
around 770 miles per hour and
convert it to 1250 kilometers per hour
it was clearly seen in the battle of
boston
with her fight against ghidorah and
rhodam number two
monster zero ghidorah or monster zero
half wings are much larger and more bad
like an appearance than most
incarnations
and the membrane of each wing is
supported by four bat-like phalanges
extending from ghidorah's wrists and
additional three phalanges that extend
from the size of ghidorah's torso
guitar can run as fast as godzilla but
his flying speed is probably faster than
mothra
as he can catch up to the argo in mexico
so maybe his speed was around
maybe 1 000 miles per hour or a 1600
kilometers per hour
and number one rodan rodan with a
wingspan of over 871 feet
has the capability of flying across
oceans without tiring
and due to his immense wingspan roland
is fast enough to keep up with
and even outfly military jets and the
uss argo and intercept mothra while she
was in the middle of a dive
rodan is indeed the fastest island as it
was faster than the f-22 raptors
that have a top speed of mach 2 or 1500
miles per hour or 2 200 kilometers per
hour
so roland would have been much faster
than them and so with that we come to
the end of the video
on the fastest titans of the
monsterverse do hit that like button for
support
and subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family and also hit that bell
button for regular updates on master
videos
till the next one take care fam
you